he didn't have enough money at the time  correct he was spending more than he was  bringing in correct  yes okay  and you gave him advice about how he  could hopefully get out of that problem  correct  yes okay and  just to be clear uh mr white because  you've testified to to some degree of  knowledge about  um  wine that you you you allege that miss  heard requested so you seem to have some  some knowledge of of mr depp's spending  miss her didn't she didn't buy any of  the dozens of properties that mr depp  owned correct  correct he owns the assets prior to  their marriage she didn't pay five  million dollars to blast hunter  thompson's ashes out of a cannon did she  not to my knowledge she didn't buy a  yacht that she couldn't afford and then  have to sell it to jk rowling did she  not to my knowledge